salut mon petit en production avant de
commencer cette vidéo puisqu'elle ne se
passe pas sur le même format que
d'habitude dans xp je veux revenir sur
des grandes expérimentation qui ont
contribué ou qui ont questionné les
sciences sociales
donc on va revenir sur ces
expérimentations là ensemble en essayant
d'y porter un est critique et
éventuellement de voir ce qu'elles ont
pu apporter aux sciences sociales
donc sans plus de bla bla on s'y colle
tout de suite pour ce premier épisode
[Musique]
en 1971 le professeur philip zimbardo
qui est spécialiste du comportement et
la psychologie sociale décide de lancer
une expérimentation d'argent tout
particulier le but annoncé de cette
expérimentation est de mettre en lumière
le fait que les individus tendent à
adopter l'attitude ou les comportements
qui sont liées au rôle qu'on va leur
donner dans un contexte donné pour cela
il lance une annonce dans le journal
proposant 15 dollars par jour aux
volontaires sur une période totale de
semaine d'il ya soixante dix jeunes
hommes adultes qui vont se proposer pour
cette expérimentation là et sur ceux 70
personnes après des tests physiques et
psychologiques il n'en restera plus que
24 ans soit la définition
d'expérimentation est assez simple ces
24 personnes moins divisés en deux
groupes d'un côté les prisonniers et de
l'autre les gardiens les deux groupes
sont mis en situation dans le sous sol
du bâtiment de psychologie de stanford
qui a été aménagé pour l'occasion on ya
mis notamment des portes ferment à clé
ainsi que des barreaux sur les fenêtres
afin de simuler un petit centre
pénitentiaire dans ce sous-sol ont donné
au gardien en uniforme kaki une matraque
ainsi qu'une paire de lunettes
réfléchissantes
le but étant ici de dépersonnaliser
l'autorité les prisonniers porte une
longue blouse blanche sans sous
vêtements ainsi que des sandales en
plastique un bas nylon et placer sur
leur tête afin de simuler un crâne rasé
le but de ces dispositions et cet
accoutrement c'est de mettre les
prisonniers dans un environnement
inhabituel et inconfortable on va
également mettre un numéro au dos de
leur blouse blanche et une chaîne sera
attaché à leur cheville
le but est encore une fois de les
oppresser et de l'aider individualisé
durant toute la durée de
l'expérimentation et gars vont se
relayer dans ce sous-sol selon des
horaires qui sont prédéfinis
les prisonniers sont quant à eux sensé
rester enfermé dans ce sous sol pendant
toute la durée de l'expérimentation une
séance de briefing eu lieu la veille de
l'expérimentation pour les gardes avec
comme seule indication le fait qu'ils
n'avaient pas le droit d'exercer des
violences physiques sur les prisonniers
on leur précise cependant que le
contrôler le bon fonctionnement de la
prison était de leur responsabilité
il est à noter que dans ce scénario le
professeur philip zimbardo don qui est à
l'origine de l'expérience sera considéré
que le directeur de la prix
et ces doctorants comme ses assistants
le but étant ici de contrôler
l'expérimentation et de pouvoir garder
un oeil sur ses évolutions
si mme bardot avait indiqué aux
prisonniers qui devait attendre chez eux
le début de l'expérimentation
ils furent en fait arrêter par la police
menotté et amené jusqu'au sous sol du
bâtiment psychologie de standford à leur
arrivée ils furent entièrement fouillé
fiche et désinfecter puis numérotées si
le premier jour de l'expérimentation se
passe à 100 heures les problèmes qu'on
prend de serre à partir du second en
effet à partir du second jour une émeute
a reparu parmi les années à ce moment là
les gardiens se porter volontaire alors
qu'il était absolument pas obligés pour
faire des heures supplémentaires afin de
saper la révolte et certains même
prirent des extincteurs pour asperger
les prisonniers qui ne voulaient pas
obéir à l'ordre
c'est à ce moment là que les choses ont
commencé à partir complètement live la
prison déjà de vin assez rapidement
insalubre et rien que le fait de se
laver de voir un privilège que les
gardes refusait fréquemment puis fut
décidée par les dires d'un de créer une
bonne cellule et le mauvais c'est lui le
but étant alors de diviser les
prisonniers est également de créer une
atmosphère de suspicion entre le
comptage des prisonniers qui avaient été
mis en place par les gardiens va devenir
un exercice très pénible pour les
prisonniers avec notamment des exercices
physiques forcé ainsi que des
humiliations pendant plusieurs heures
les matelas vont être retirés de la
mauvaise cellules ce qui fait que les
prisonniers qui étaient dans cette
cellule là vont dormir nu directement
sur le sol pendant plusieurs nuits les
prisonniers furent fréquemment privés de
nourriture et on les oblige à même à
endurer une idée force et voir des actes
d'humiliation sexuelle ou de plusieurs
jours certains prisonniers vont
commencer à montrer des signes de
dérangement émotionnel aiguë deux
d'entre eux souffrent de troubles si
importante qui furent écartés de
l'expérimentation et deux cobayes varlet
remplacé à ce moment là sixième jour
christine hamas là qui était une
ancienne étudiante de
10 mar 2 va arriver dans la prison afin
de mener des interviews en constatant
l'état de la prison et surtout l'état
psychologique des détenus
elle va inciter fille d'une mare d'eau à
arrêter complètement l'expérimentation
c'est donc à partir de ce sixième jour
sur les deux semaines prévu que philip
zimbardo va mettre fin à
l'expérimentation
l'expérience de standford prix donc fin
le 20 août 1971 ces résultats permettent
de démontrer l'impressionner habilité et
l'obéissance des individus en présence
d'un support social et institutionnel
fort
il confirme de fait que placer dans de
certaines situations avec des rôles bien
particulier le comportement des
individus temps à muter en fonction de
ce qu'on en attend d'eux en cela la
conclusion est assez classe en stature
que les individus vont arrêter de faire
la différence entre leur personnalité
leur individualité et le rôle qui leur
était attendue et qui leur a été
attribué et est ce que dit mme bardot
surnomme les faits lucie faire
l'expérience d'un projeté zimbardo sur
la scène internationale et elle va faire
de lui une référence et une autorité sur
la thématique de la psychologie sociale
ces travaux ont sans conteste influencé
des générations de chercheurs
travaillant notamment sur les théories
du comportement ainsi que de l'
influence
sauf que l'expérimentation des bidons et
bidons pour plusieurs raisons deuxième
bardot a truqué son expérimentation afin
de confirmer ces suppositions et non
afin de les remettre en question ce qui
est la base du travail scientifique
en premier lieu il est faux de dire
qu'aucune indication formelle été donné
au gardien au contraire l'équipe de
zimbardo a fourni au gardien toute une
palette d'actions possibles afin de
presser et les garder sous contrôle les
prisonniers une compilation de méthodes
d' influence qui ont été tirées des
travaux en psychologie sociale qui ont
été menées jusque là et qui ont permis
au gardien d'asseoir leur autorité en
affaiblissant émotionnellement les
détenus de plus durant l'expérimentation
le docteur zimbardo va souvent
outrepasser son statut de régulateur et
d'observateurs pour intervenir et donner
des conseils au gardien afin de presser
et d'affaiblir encore plus les
prisonniers de plus les conclusions de
20-7 bardot de son expérimentation vont
complètement mettre de côté une
problématique majeure un problème lié à
ce qu'on appelle les exigences de la
situation expérimental en somme il est
apparu qu'une grande majorité des
participants avaient conscience des
résultats attendus par l'expérimentation
ainsi la plupart des étudiants présents
dans ce sous-sol savez ce que cherchait
zimbardo à savoir que les individus
tendent à se conformer au rôle qui leur
est donné du coup on peut se demander
quelle partie des comportements est
engendrée par la situation
d'incarcération et quelle partie des
comportement est influencé par
l'expérimentation et ses suppositions
à partir du moment où on peut pas faire
la différence entre ces deux effets là
alors l'expérience ne peut être valide
enfin selon zimbardo cette
expérimentation c'est la preuve que tout
à chacun est capable d'agir ainsi dans
cette situation de données aussi il
implique que toutes les individus
auraient réagi de la même façon à son
expérimentation peut encore origine leur
milieu leur sexe ou leur âge
or deux constats s'opposent à ces
divisions en premier lieu tous les
individus placés dans l'expérimentation
sur deux jeunes hommes blancs placé pour
la plupart dans l'expérimentation par
leurs professeurs
or on se doute déjà de l'ampleur des
billets qui sont amenés par la position
d'autorité scientifique et d'autorité
institutionnels quand les professeurs
sur leurs étudiants outre cela zimbardo
affirme que les individus se conforme de
façon plus ou moins homogènes au rôle
qui leur est attribué ignorante de fait
en fait toutes les divergences qui vont
exister pendant ces six jours
d'expérimentation entre les différents
individus
c'est un élément important qui va être
complètement négligé par zimbardo lors
de l'écriture de ces conclusions et qui
va de fait fausse et l'interprétation de
l'expérimentation du coup ça donne une
interprétation assez erronée de
l'expérimentation à savoir que tout
individu en ignorant ses caractères
propres est capable de se conformer à ce
qu'on attend de lui à part son moment où
on lui ou c'est lui a ordonné par une
institution ou une idéologie qu'il
conçoit comme légitime ces critiques
méthodologiques ont largement été
exploitée dans le livre histoire d'un
mensonge de thibault le textile dans ce
livre l'auteur ton a souligné que
zimbardo et peut-être bien plus un
idéologue qu'un scientifique
l'exemple de zimbardo n'arrive pas dans
n'importe quel contexte c'est dans un
contexte de remise en question de la
guerre du vietnam et donc de remise en
question de l'ordre étatique dans ce
contexte zimbardo va chercher à marquer
les esprits
soutenant ainsi que leur pratique est
capable de confort mais les individus
pour les rendre capables du pire dans
des situations de données
cette vision il aura notamment
l'occasion de la soutenir un peu après
l'expérimentation avec des émeutes
qu'auront lieu notamment marie de prison
de cinq cantines et dat ik qu'il reverra
sur le devant de la scène avec le
scandale de la prison d'abou ghraïb en
je sais pas si vous vous rappelez cette
affaire-là et notamment des clichés qui
sont remontées au sein des médias
c'était juste des choses affreuses mené
par les gardes américains de la prison
d'abou ghraïb sur les prisonniers
on parle d'acte de sévices physiques de
sévices psychologiques et autres choses
affreuses qui ont eu lieu dans ce cadre
là à cette occasion de nombreux
parallèles furent tissés entre ce qui
s'est passé au goût ghraib et les
résultats l'expérience de zimbardo enfin
l'expérience malgré qu'elle ait eu pas
mal de critiques méthode
comme j'aime le faire elle va encore
largement autorité au sein du monde
scientifique
elle est utilisée notamment dans le
monde de la recherche mais également
dans le monde militant pour souligner
l'effet de l'ordre social et de
l'autorité sur le comportement des
individus
mais alors l'expérimentation pose une
question est ce qu'on peut utiliser la
science pour faire passer un message ou
pour exposer une île et dans un premier
temps on se répandait de là en fait
pourquoi pas dans la mesure où
effectivement il ya eu des vraies abus
dans les prisons abou greïn et dans
d'autres est effectivement encore
aujourd'hui beaucoup de prisonniers sont
soumis à des traitements parfaitement
inhumain mais en fait non c'est pas une
bonne chose du tout en premier lieu
c'est pathétique et surtout c'est très
très dangereux car si on instrumentalise
la science alors elle perd sa force
principale qui est son impartialité
c'est cela qui la distingue des autres
écrit c'est une remise en question
perpétuelle de ce qui est su donc même
si c'est fait avec la meilleures
intentions
cette invasion de l'idéologie dans la
science ne peut provoquer que plus de
relativisme dans ce qui est transmis
voilà pourquoi une expérimentation ne
doit pas être acceptée parce qu'elle est
séduisante et bien parce qu'elle prouve
des choses à l'aide d'une méthodologie
rigoureuse et transparente ce que
zimbardo ne parvient pas à faire avec
cette expérimentation
[Musique]